[Musik]
wollen wir rein ins Ende gehen rein ich
war noch gar nicht drin
[Musik]
sende jetzt dürfen wir kein Schwachsinn
machen jetzt nicht schlagen oder
irgendwas
du hast Blöcke zum hochbauen ja klar
[Musik]
abschießen sie mal auf diese Feuer da
oben auf die ich auch Ziele und immer in
Bewegung bleiben immer mal auf den
Enderdrachen gucken du könntest dich mal
überall da wo noch Licht brennt wo du
auch so Feuer brennt hoch bauen die
Teile abschießen der kann nicht
runterwerfen pass auf Explosion Schaden
auf Idioten ich habe euch vorher gefragt
ob Explosionsschutz mit drauf soll
komplett aus
Laser warte mal
Drachen ist direkt bei mir der hat mich
runtergeschubst Laser
das ist sinnvoll
Laser ich wollte mich hoch bauen der hat
mich einfach runtergezogen
[Musik]
nicht an die Dinger muss ich mich hoch
bauen oder ich habe Angst vor dem
auch
keine Blöcke mehr
ich probiere was ich probiere was
über mir
ich brauche Blöcke von dir
Baby
süchtig nach dir
Leute kann ich nicht hier schon schlagen
ich mache mir in die Hosen sondern ich
weiß nicht wo du bist komm mal in die
Mitte
ich bin in der Mitte
okay von wo zieht er sich noch Energie
nur noch von da oben das heißt wir
müssen nur noch dahin wenn lenkt den ab
um mit
zu
sehr gut sehr gut
er geht wieder weg
[Musik]
es gibt doch gar nicht Leute ich
schwör's euch ihr könnt euch nicht
vorstellen wie nervös ich bin ne ich war
noch nie so nervös nicht mal Abitur
Klausur
ich mache
ich habe für dich
[Musik]
Sander jetzt schlag ihn
hast du geschafft das letzte
abzuschießen wir haben alles
abgeschossen jetzt müssen wir nur noch
warten bis er runterkommt
s sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut Handy den
letzten Pfeil gebe ich dir
ich habe keine Pfeile mehr
oh wenn ich in den letzten Teil gebe und
wir können ihn nicht töten
ich suche meine Handy
bist du in der Drachen getötet Handy wir
haben es geschafft
und wir sind
nicht ich habe gesagt wir sind gut
vorbereitet
für die mit der nächsten Pizza
gut geschlagen ich habe den
so ab die ganze Erfahrungspunkte ich
glaube die habe ich irgendwie
eingesammelt
[Musik]
Level 68 plötzlich also ich glaube wir
können jetzt äh dahinten das ist jetzt
dieses Portal da wenn man elytra haben
will aber das machen wir jetzt erstmal
nicht wir gehen jetzt erstmal hier rein
damit Minecraft durchgespielt haben
jetzt springen wir hier rein ja
[Musik]
jetzt kommt nämlich der Abspann oh mein
Gott Leute wir haben es geschafft und
wir sind nicht mal annähernd gestorben
geil einfach geil ich bin jetzt im
Stream gekommen was habe ich verpasst
ach nichts dicker kann ich jetzt endlich
mal dein Haus mit TNT schlachten
nee nee das das machen wir nicht die
Leute kriegen ja die Welt noch zum
Download okay ich bin so stolz Leute ich
finde ich habe überragend gespielt ich
glaube Mittelalter wäre schützende Bogen
genau bei dir gewesen
was heißt denn Drachenei müssen wir
dieses Drachenei hätten wir das in der
Mitte abbauen müssen diese schwarze Ei
oder was heißt das ich soll noch mal
mein Bett hierhin setzen und noch mal
reingehen und noch mal schauen dass ich
das Kriege oder wie aber wenn ich jetzt
reingehe kommt der ist der in der Drache
dann schon wieder da Nein ja komm Sandy
ich gehe noch mal rein okay wie soll ich
denn jetzt da drunter eine Fackel setzen
das ist Bedrock Idioten schlagen das
Ding schlagen draufklicken Rechtsklick
[Musik]
dann wollte mich verarschen jetzt
fackelt runter
[Musik]
das Beste was mir je passiert ist es tut
so gut wie du mich liebst
mich doch nicht mit der Erfahrung
das stimmt kommt das Song Kompromiss wir
machen demnächst nochmal loser Stream
wir wissen noch nicht wann war
wahrscheinlich nächste Woche
mit euch wie wir die Dichte Fichte bauen
und dann nach dem dichte Fichte bauen
geben wir euch sieht und Download warum
ist Sandra Stream so unscharf ja die
glaube ich an der streamerin
[Musik]
ist natürlich eine Geschmackssache das
ist klar das war's mit Minecraft loser
für heute hey wir haben einfach den
Enderdrachen
[Musik]
Erlebnisse mit euch hier wieder
geschaffen ja wirklich wieder super
Stream mit Dir gewesen
[Musik]